out to go and rest my name is Paora Pat
welcome to another awesome episode of at
last I did not mean to do that [ __ ] Oh
skills oh so good oh my [ __ ] on
[ __ ] Jane is [ __ ] cow already yay
oh my god so smart
did you see that [ __ ] did you see that I
saw that damn you know what sometimes
sometimes I know what you're thinking
you're like oh my god Pierce is such an
idiot how did you not figure that [ __ ]
out
well not today sorry I'm I'm rubbing an
inning way too much I get it
what's my objective
basement basement I can't even handle
the hallways there well left well at
least I get to do some yarding okay I
guess this is the basement huh after you
you go now you go I don't fight me just
kidding I would never hurt you ha ha ha
you flinched
just kidding ok alright
can't be that bad it's just a basement
ah god damn it hi hi
huh confidential not anymore
that's a sweet-ass bed you [ __ ] Meryl
that was easy who's that not me I mean
nothing
this looks like a lot of like Grave
Encounters have you seen that movie when
they have a camera or whatever
oh geez wave yo hey
oh nice I mean yeah geez those fans are
awesome oh I've been here before
all right here it is all right I'll
teach you not to mess with me Oh what oh
no oh no this is very bad news for me
very very bad bad bad Batman Batman
Batman Batman not bad man all right here
we go Shh calm down
Oh
put it out and never heard that well
there's another generator way to be
subtle you little [ __ ] calm down more
in what kind of name is that
I need to find some batteries man
okay what oh oh I'm sorry about the door
quite a head lady go
oh that ass
all right we're escaping here later is
he turning the mob
oh come on
oh this is not good for my street cred
you [ __ ] mouth
oh come on push it's [ __ ] intense
main episode I can't see anything
ah baby baby it's a wild world no no no
no no no I tried to get but hey how you
doing there there's absolutely no
[ __ ] where I hide Oh uncle
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] me where the [ __ ]
are we going I know nobody's no one
there we go that was one that was
[ __ ] one
okay while we're progressing at least
yeah yeah little louder see if I give a
[ __ ]
idiot oh that's great
oh come on you gotta let me endure we
are really [ __ ] oh okay we can go here
okay it doesn't look like it's coming
where are all the batteries in this game
where have all the batter is gone and
we're all oh hey hey I know you think
we're friends but we're [ __ ] not -
stay the [ __ ] away please
get it up get it I've done it and done
it engine run [ __ ] run you're not
welcome in my house
damn I thought that [ __ ] had us oh
thanks sweet Jesus man the batteries are
not faster than a [ __ ] hooker on
steroids where is the other switch where
is it shut up okay we need to get out of
this hallway
Oh baby you're not welcome sorry sorry
sorry sorry
why me
I'm gonna take a break hahaha I'm back I
took a break I know we can do this I
[ __ ] know we can do this where is the
final [ __ ] switch huh I actually wear
a jet you dangle old dick okay it's not
in there so unless we missed oh it's on
Oh return to where return to secure to
control to unlock the main door oh oh I
know where that is
adios suck-up I think this is yeah this
is a
what
where did we come from I've been in here
I know this because I know that yes
squeeze through Oh
my nipples are extremely hard cool cool
that was awesome
that was awesome well someone fell haha
it's always funny when people fell okay
let's see here
security room this way hey gents um oh
witness so they they make witness go to
bathroom another oh another face - well
that is just pretty some pretty [ __ ] get
it sorry
oh my god I guess that's what happens
when you have gonorrhea ha ha ha
what about in here that's what happens
when you eat a toilet no wait what well
this is how the cafeteria looks in my
old school if it was I wouldn't be
surprised what did you do
oh he shut out his intestines who closed
the door did you close the door no well
then who was it huh was it you oh hello
who closed it at the door huh don't make
me angry
oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ] he's literally
broke down the security door okay well I
guess we don't want to [ __ ] it with him
ah don't touch me oh how dare you
I'm sorry my son I didn't want to have
to do this to you but you can't leave
I don't touch me not yet I am not yet
for you to win this are at faith love
see it don't show me your Daniel our
Lord the walrider
tearing his truth into the unbelief whoa
whoa way out of this place is the truth
accept the gospel
again again I'm happy cuz that looks
awesome and I'm sad because I know that
shit's gonna [ __ ] scare me I pres hope
you enjoyed this episode as always if
you did go ahead and leave a like it
helps me out a lot
subscribe to coma bread today I'll see
you tomorrow in the next 1000 Brea's
love you
whoa okay oh [ __ ] go through